ça va tirer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on vient
j'accueille maintenant lara fabian
là
non ça va bonsoir bonsoir thierry
comment ça va ça va il ya longtemps
qu'on ne t'a pas vu rappelons leur actu
est basé en belgique à bruxelles oui
dans l'immeuble de mes parents j'ai rien
petite chambre aux dernières étapes
revient avec un nouvel album qui
s'appelle neuf voilà parce que je les
fais en 9 minutes voilà
la rage je t'aime beaucoup mais je me
rends compte que j'ai plus grand chose à
te dire
que c'est parce que j'étais numéro
l'impression qu'on a fait le tour pour
ben écoute je vais y aller ce que je
voulais dire quand même c'est que mon
album me faut l'acheter donc ils
s'appellent nov lara tu vas le thalys
dans 20 minutes il faut pas traîner non
plus jusqu'à 9 sur 20
elles ne marchent pas à celle là non
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu